[Musik]
die grünen würden sie sagen sind sie auf
einer skala von eins bis drei
eigentlich sehr wenig heißt 1 der
eigentliche und technisch gut
auch das skala von 1 bis 3 ist sechs
natürlich erstmal gar nicht waren
der syrer er zweimal hat er mir das
mikro schon weggenommen
aber heute bis 2014 schon das erste
bekenntnis zu grün kann er sein
es ist das mit abstand beste plakat von
mir sagen sie einfach zu grün also da
hätten sie mehr aufstiegschancen also
dass seehofer
er schiebt sie nach berlin ins ausland
schickt er sie ab als er dieses mal
jemanden ab aber so schnell gehen leider
abschiebungen in deutschland mitnehmen
leider nicht sonst haben das cleveres
anfrage und ich habe den text
vorbereitet mit einer kruste dass sie
sich mal vor gewalt aber zweimal mit
seinen zwei mal den zelten gibt es aber
nicht
[Musik]
daher bin ich sehr so scheisse scheisse
richtigstellen bin ja aber die scheiße
sind mitglied seit 86 ihm aufgetreten in
bayern ist noch ein bisschen langsamer
aber jetzt können wir mal so langsam
wird mir ausgerechnet das heißt sie
haben nur 30 jahre gebraucht um
festzustellen dass das ne scheiß partei
stichwort barmherzigkeit und obergrenze
wo wir steht das c in csu champagner
kaviar de la crème brulée check24 ist
das ja nicht mehr
jesus hat ja auch nicht gesagt diese
woche mache ich nur zwei hilft krank und
eines obergrenze warum ich kenne ich
eingetreten wie er kennt mich unter
weiterer von weitem auch der not wie dem
was ausrichten von media deutschland das
sagen der schönen gruß wohnung ist dass
er wirklich ein modell spitznamen ich
sollte sie kommen gelohnt grüßen
ich sollte von lump grüßen er war 30
jahre lang ihr freund in der partei ist
jetzt aber ausgetreten und ziemlich
sauer können sich nicht mehr erinnern
kann ich mir jetzt abonnieren
er macht jetzt wahrscheinlich ziemlich
krawall wenn sie ein wenig erinnern
können und die schlechte mit der inneren
sicherheit in deutschland
was halten sie denn von der jamaika
koalition nichts absolut nichts stehen
aber wenn die grünen dabei wären dann
wären sie dann wären sie nicht mehr die
partei mit den dümmsten vorschlägen da
ich glaube ich aber ist es nicht besser
für unsere sicherheit wenn die grünen in
der regierung sitzen dass sie die ganze
zeit sie auch beobachten können
ich glaube das ist sicherlich nicht der
richtige maßstab gibt auch viele grün
mit dem wir vernünftig reden kann aber
besser ist schon mal die csu
alleinregierung bilden ja die csu statt
paarungsbereit und diese frohe botschaft
die verkündigt jetzt den beiden die auch
heute zufällig in nürnberg sind
frau roth herr hofreiter ich komme ich
komme mit froher kunde die csu ist
bereit wo 44 jamaika klar wir wollen hat
echte politik machen während die csu hat
meistens damit zufrieden ist wenn sie
ein bissel rumschreien kann und
irgendwelche posten hat also hinzu
dienstwägen im chatroom form kommen
scheiße schon wieder groko tja schade
spd schade deutschland und damit zurück
ins studio wo man schon wieder groß
[Applaus]